ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى ساعه اخباريه نخصص
معظمها لتغطيه التطورات في السودان ونبدا
بالعناوين
الدعم السريع يعلن تمديد الهدنه في
السودان الاثنتين وسبعين ساعتين استجابه
النداءات الدوليه والاقليميه
[تصفيق]
والوضع الامني في الخرطوم من اسوا عمليه
نهبه في الخرطوم بحري وانظر منه
نحو اليوم العاشر تمضي عمليات الاجلاء
لرعايه الدول العربيه والاجنبيه والاسيويه
من شرق السودان الى عدد
مركز الاجلاء الرئيسي عالقون يطالبنا
بالخروج
وفي اخبارنا كذلك في هذه الساعه
اوكرانيا تناقز نفسها بشان الهجوم المضاد
يقول انه سيبدا حتى من دون المقاتلات
وجيشه يقول ان الامر مستحيل
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى التفاصيل سنبداها
باخر التطورات الخاصه بالسودان فقبل
انتهاء الهدنه الخامسه في السودان تعلن
قوه دعم السريع عن هدنه سادسه هذه الهدنه
كسابقتها لمده 72 ساعه تبدا من منتصف
الليله لفتح الممرات الانسانيه ولتسهيل
الوصول الى المناطق الامنه الى الان لم
يصدر الجيش السوداني ورد فعل على تمديد
هذه الهدنه ولكن ايضا في الاعلانات
السابقه كان الجيش يؤكد موافقته في وقت
لاحق ورغم الهدنه المعلنه لان الالتزام
الكامل بها يبقى منقوصا فعلى مدار الايام
ثلاثه الماضيه كانت الاشتباكات متفارقه في
الصالحه والحلفايه وجبرى والصحافه فمثلا
تم خرق الهدنه اليوم في منطقه السوق
الشعبي في ام درمان حيث تم رصد اصوات
الاشتباكات في المنطقه متابعه
[موسيقى]
في خبر اخر كان اكد العميد نبيل عبد الله
المتحدث باسم الجيش السوداني انها قوات
الجيش تمكنت من السيطره على 17 ولايه
وفرضت سيطره بنسبه 80% في ولايتي الخرطوم
وغرب دارفور التي تشهد مواجهات قبليه يجري
العمل على وقفها
على كل الولايات 17 والسيطره
يعني بنسبه 80%
في ولايتي الخرطوم واما ولايه غرب
الفردفان غربي دارفور فهذه هي طبعا بها
متغير ومتغير الاخير الذي تمصل في اندلاع
الصراع القبلي والذي يعني الان يجري
احتواءه بواسطه السلطات المحليه هناك عن
طريق لجنه امن الولايه وهذا المسلحه يعني
تسيطر تماما على جميع مقراتها بما فيها
القياده العامه بما فيها بيت الضيافه وحتى
منطقه القصر الجمهوري حديثهم يعني
وتركيزهم على السيطره على العاصمه ليست
ليس ليس صحيحا
قوه الدعم السريعه اتهمت هي الاخرى الجيش
بمهاجمه مواقع تمركزها في عدد من مناطق
الخرطوم بالمدافع والطائرات بينوا الدعم
السريع عشر الى ان طائرات الجيش ما تزال
تحلق في سماء الخرطوم وتنتهك الهدنه الدعم
السريع قال ان الجيش يستعد لشني هجوم في
العاصمه الخرطوم في مدينه الحلفايه وانظر
وبحري
[موسيقى]
متابعه هذا الموضوع بالمزيد من التفاصيل
مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم الصحفي عمار بوشيبا
سيد عمار اهلا بك معنا نبدا باخر التطورات
من عندك هل هناك فعليا لطائرات تحلق في
سماء الخرطوم كما جاء في بيان دعم السريع
نعم يعني حتى هذه الساعه لم نرصد تحليق
للطائرات ولكن هنالك عدد من الاخبار التي
نشرت قبل قليل بان هنالك تحليق للطائرات
الحربيه فوق سماع مدينه ام درمان وهنالك
مصادر ايضا محليه تتحدث عن اشتباكات تدور
الان في منطقه الكادر بمنطقه شمال البحري
وفي هذه المنطقه نستمع الى عددنا
الاشتباكات المتفرقه الان في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم هذا كله ياتي بالتزامن مع الهدنه
التي ربما الان بدا الحديث عنها الهدنه
السادسه بشكل واضح وكبير من خلال هذه اعمل
من خلال هذه الحرب والان ربما كثير جدا من
الاراء تنتشر وكثير جدا من التعليقات حول
هذه الهدنه ولكن ما زلنا نستمع الى عدد من
اصوات الاشتباكات المتقطعه والمتفرقه بين
رضوى اخر من هذه الشبكات التي تحدثت عنها
هل هي اشتباكات متفارقه تستعمل فيها اسلحه
خفيفه متوسطه هل هي عباره عن حرب شوارع ام
ان هناك استمرار لاستخدام المدفعيه
والاسلحه الثقيله كذلك
ربما قلت يعني استخدام المدفعيه الثقيله
والاسلحه الثقيله في الايام
الماضيه وهذه الايام كسابقاتها الاولى
ولكن هذا يبدو من خلال الصوت ومن خلال
العمليات العسكريه ومن خلال عدد من
التصريحات العسكريه بان عمليه الطبشيط
ربما تمضي الى عمليات كاروه فروه عمليات
اشتباكات متقطعه في عدد من المناطق وعدد
من الاحصنه التي تتحصن فيها قوات الدعم
السريع والمناطق التي تحازي انتشارا للقوه
عمار اسمح لي وابقى معي ساعود لك للوقوف
على المزيد من التفاصيل ولكن كنا تحدثنا
مشاهدينا في بدايه هذه النشره عن بيان كان
اصدره الدعم السريع نقف كذلك على تفاصيل
هذا البيان مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم يوسف عزت
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
سيد يوسف اهلا بك معنا سيد يوسف هناك
موافقه وهناك كلام مؤكد على تمديد هذه
الهدنه 72 ساعه صحيح
نعم صحيح نعم ماذا في التفاصيل
نحن
اعلنا منذ اليوم الاول اننا مع الهدنه
الانسانيه وافقنا على هذه خمسه هدى وهذه
الهدنه السادسه موافقتنا دائما تاتي لصالح
مواطني ولايه الخرطوم والمدن الاخرى
الهدنه ليست في الخرطوبه حتى في المدن
الاخرى التي تدور فيها معارك غير مغطيه
بالاعلام
تحدثت عن مدن اخرى سيد يوسف ما المدن
الاخرى لو نذكرها ونتحدث عن نسق للشبكات
فيها وما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه هذه الهدنه
نعم
في
الدمازين في نيالا في عدد من المدن ليست
مغطيه هنالك مناوشات تحدث من بين القوات
المتواجده في تلك المناطق بالدعم السريع
والجيش في جنينه تحدث في اشتباكات قبليه
لمده اكثر من ثلاثه ايام فنحن نعلم نعلن
هدنه نع لصالح المواطنين وبالذات ولايه
الخرطوم وهنالك انقطاع للمياه في بحره
هنالك انقطاع للكهرباء
لا بد لا بد من معالجه هذه الاوضاع ونحن
التزمنا بالهدنه لهذا الهدف وطالبنا الطرف
الاخر منذ اليوم منذ الهدنه الاولى ان
يتوقف عن قصف المدنيين ان يتوقف عن عن
استخدام الاسلحه الثقيله في المدن التي
كلفت المواطنين الكثير جدا هذه مناسبات لم
تجد الاستجابه نحن اعلنا الامس يعني
الهدنه كانت ساريه هاجمت قوه من 300 مركبه
قواتنا المرتكزه في الصالحه وبغطاء جوي
يستطعنا استطاعت قواتنا ان تقبلهم خسائر
فادحه واسرع اعداد كبيره منهم معركه
منشوره في وسائل الاعلام لايف
يعني نحن في هدنه واعلنا التزامنا بهدنه
ايضا هنالك طائرات تتحدى هذا هذه الهدنه
السريع ما يسمع من رصاص هو مضادات الدعم
السريعه الارضيه تتصدى لهجوم طيران لكن
على ارض الواقع في
ولايه في
كل
للجيش او قوات تتحرك من مكان الى مكان
للجيش هذه مساله حسمت منذ ايام لا يوجد
تحرك للجيش داخل ولايه الخرطوم بشكل كامل
عاده في محيط القياده يسيطرون على بوابه
واحده
فقط لنتاكد من هذا التفصيل تقول بان لا
وجود للجيش داخل الخرطوم بينما الجيش
السوداني يقول بانه يسيطر على ما نسبته
80% من المناطق التي تحدث فيها اشتباكات
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد اشتباك بين الجيش والدعم هنالك
بوابه واحده
لقوات الجيش سيد يوسف فقط لنفهم هذا
الكلام ان لم يكن وجود لمشاه كما ذكرت منذ
قليل ان تحدثت عن خلو الداخل في الخرطوم
لاي قوات تابعه للجيش اذا هذه الاشتباكات
بين من ومن ان كنتم انتم فقط تستعملون
مضادات طائرات وتتحدث عن حضور الجيش فقط
في اطراف او في تخوم العاصمه السودانيه
هذه الاشتباكات كيف تفسر
اين من الذي قال هنالك اشتراكات نحن اليوم
يتحدثون عن الشبكات
اشتباكات في ساحه الاعلام لكن على ارض
الواقع نحن نتحرك اليوم
داخلنا الثلاثه في ولايه الخرطوم على
قواتي والتقى قاده العمليات الميداليه
لا يوجد شيء هنا طيران هنالك طيران يحوم
تتصدى له المضادات لا يوجد شيء عمليا على
ارض الواقع هذه مجرد ابداعات في في شاشات
التلفزيون
السوشيال ميديا نعم وضحت هذه الفكره في
بيانكم سيد يوسف قلتم بانكم استجابه
لنداءات دوليه واقليميه وكذلك محليه
اعلنتم تمديد هذه الهدنه الانسانيه ل72
ساعه
وستكون هذه الهدنه لفتح الممرات الانسانيه
وتسهيل حركه المواطنين نفهم بانكم
تتعاونون مع هذه الجهات ومن تكون هذه
الجهات لفتح هذه الممرات الامنه خاصه
في الداخل في الداخل
نحن الان لدينا اكثر من اسبوعين ولذيذ في
الحرب لدينا صلاه مع المواطنين في المناطق
التي نوجد بها هنالك لجان من الشباب من
شباب المقاومه هنالك اللجان من من من شباب
الاحياء يعملون ويتعاونون مع القوات في
حفظ الامن في تقديم الخدمات للمواطنين
مثلا في في بحر نحن تعاونا مع عدد من
الشباب في نقل المياه للمواطنين لانه بحري
من اليوم الاول المياه مقطوعه فيها
تعاملنا مع عدد من الناس في تسهيل حركه
الناس الى المستشفيات الى العبور بين
المدن الثلاثه
يوسف عن شباب متطوع اليست هناك منظمات
محليه او دوليه تتعاون معها
[موسيقى]
منظمات ختاما هو باختصار انت كرمت هل
سنكون امام هدى في كل مره يتم تمديدها
الاثنين ساعه او ان هناك كلام
لامكانيه ان تكون هناك هدنه مستمره ودائمه
اعلن انه مستعد لوقت شعبي لاطلاق النار
اذا كان الطرف الاخر او القائد العام
السابق للجيش البرهان اذا كان لديه القدره
على ايقاف الحرب نحن واعلنا ان الحرب التي
تدور او اختراق الهدن يكشف عن المراكز
متعدده داخل الجيش لانه هنالك ان القائد
العام للجيش ليس لديه سيطره على على
القوات المسلحه بدليل انك هذه الهدنه
كل الهدن تم اختراقها وتم عدم الالتزام
بها بشكل معلن وبطيران ومدافع فنحن نشك ان
الجيش الان قيادته قياده هي الق
ياده او القياده المعروفه هنالك لو سمحت
انت اسميت البرهان قائد القوات المسلحه
السابق
نعم نحن نقول
هذه يعني هو لا يسيطر هنالك ثمه مركز جديد
لقياده الجيش لا نعرف من يقود من يحرك
العمليات ولكن قلنا اذا البركان لديه ما
زال هو القائد العام للجيش وهذا كلام معلن
لغايه العام لغايه قوات الدعم السريع اذا
كان البرهان ما زال هو القائد العام للجيش
فعلا فليو في الحرب ونحن مستعدين الموقف
هذا اليقين بان البرهان لا يحكم بان هذه
الاوامر لا تصدر عنه
بدليل انه يصدر بيان ويقول انه انه يوافق
على الهدنه وعبر الناطق الرسمي وهذه
الهدنه الخامسه فشلت فشل في غاب الحرب
هنالك ضرب للمدنيين هنالك طيران يقوم
ويقصف مواقعنا هنالك مدفعيه كانت تضرب
فاذا كان انت غايجي جيش وتلتزم امام شعبك
وامام العالم بانك توافق على هدنه مدتها
272 ساعه او ساعه واحده ولا تستطيع لمده
خمسه هدى الايفاء بهدنه واحده او التزام
بهدنه واحده لاحظ الهدنه الثانيه اعلن
الجيش يلتزم بها من الساعه السادسه
السادسه بالضبط تحركت الطائرات وضربت هذا
كان هنالك تحدي لقرار البرهان نفسه
واضح ولكن لما تتحدثون في بيانكم عن ان
هذه الخروقات المستمره من القوات
الانقلابيه تتحدثون يعني لما تقولون قوات
انقلابيه هذا التوصيف للجيش عموما او
تتحدثون عن مجموعات معينه داخل الجيش
نحن حسب نحن حسب راينا الاول الذي قلناه
ان الجيش تم اختطاف القرار في الجيش هنالك
مجموعه داخل الجيش تامر معها البرهان هي
التي دبرت جر الجيش لكل هذه العمليه
العسكريه جر البلاد لكل هذا العنف هذه
المجموعه مجموعه انقلابيه تريد اعاده
النظام السابق هذه مجموعه اسلاميه هذه
مجموعه لديها انتماك ترفض العمليه
السياسيه باعتبارها بواحده من شروطها تنزل
صفوف الجيش من العناصر المؤدلجه والعناصر
المنتمله لنظام السابق
هذه الانقلاب على العمليه السياسيه وان
ينفرد البرهان بالحكم والاسلاميين يشكل له
حاضنه حرب التي نواجه واضحه الفكره شكرا
على المشاركه من الخرطوم يوسف عزت
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوه الدعم السريع
شكرا لك شكرا جزيلا
نعود من جديد الى تفاصيل الارض من داخل
الخرطوم مع الصحفي عماره بوشيبا عمار
تحدثنا عن التطورات الميدانيه ولكن ماذا
عن التطورات الانسانيه هل هناك
معابر امنه لخروج النازحين خاصه وان هذه
العمليه يقال بانها مستمره لو تؤكد لنا
ذلك
نعم يعني هنالك كثيره جدا من الممرات
الانسانيه التي تم من خلالها اخراج كثير
من العالقين وكثير جدا من المرضى وحتى
وصول كثير من الجرحى الى عدد من
المستشفيات ساهمت هذه الهدنه ولو بشكل
قليل او شكل فعال فاعليه جزئيه في ان يصل
او تصل كثير جدا من الحالات الانسانيه
والجرحى الى عدد من المستشفيات او ان تمر
عدد من المؤن لعدد من المناطق في احياء
العاصمه الخرطوم وحتى في عدد من الولايات
التي تشهد ربما توترا امنيا مثل ولايه
دارفور هذه الهدى نعم ساهمت ولو بشكل دقيق
او شكل نوعا ما قليل ولكنها اسهمت بشكل
واضح في النوع ما ان تبصد عدد من الممرات
الامنه لكثير من المحتاجين اليها لك عمار
ابو شيبه صحفي كنت معنا من الخرطوم
قبل ذلك مشاهدينا كان نستقبل وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
استقبل المبعوث الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقاليه السودانيه السفيره دفع الله
الحاج علي وجرى خلال اللقاء بحث الاوضاع
الراهنه في السودان وقد اكد وزير الخارجيه
السعودي على دعوه الرياض للتهدئه وتغذيب
المصلحه الوطنيه ووقف اشكال التصعيد
العسكري كافه بما يحافظ على مقدرته
ومكتسبات السودان وشعبه
من جهته دعا الامين العام لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي جاسم محمد البديوي لتغليف مصلحه
السودان الوطني وذلك خلال لقائه المبعوثه
الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي
بالسودان دفع الله الحاج علي كما دعا من
عام مجلس التعاون الى التهدئه ووقف كل
اشكال التصعيد في السودان مؤكدا الحرص على
امن السودان وعلى سلامته واستقراره وتماسك
الدوله السودانيه ومؤسساتها وشدد البديوي
على مسانده مجلس التعاون الخليجي للسودان
لمواجهه كافه التحديات ولتحقيق تطلعات
الشعب
اكد رئيس مصري عبد الفتاح السيسي ضروره
عدم التدخل الخارجي في الازمه السودانيه
كما اكد السيسي في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع
رئيس الوزراء الياباني
على ضروره الوقف الفوري ودائم لاطلاق
النار في السودان
تلت التطورات في السودان جانبا مهما من
المباحثات حيث اكدت لدوله رئيس الوزراء
الرؤيه المصريه القائمه على ضروره الوقف
الفوري والدائم والشامل لاطلاق النار في
السودان اهميه امتناع اي طرف خارجي عن
التدخل في الازمه باعتبارها شانا سودانيا
خالصا بما يسهل من نزع فتيل الازمه ويحود
دون تفاقمها
قبل ذلك كان حذر المتحدث باسم العمليه
السياسيه في السودان خالد عمر يوسف على
حسابه في تويتر حذر من انتشار المواجهات
العرقيه في البلاد في ظل احتدام الاقتتال
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع مشددا على
ان استمرار الحرب سيضعف الدوره المدنيه
تلقائيا ويتحول لدور هامشي كما قال مشيرا
الى ان الواقفه المدني الديمقراطي يجب ان
يكون بالضغط لوقف الحرب وتكوين جبهه مدنيه
ديمقراطيه واسعه مطالبا بجيش واحد يتم
الوصول اليه بالاتفاق على خطه شامله
للاصلاح الامني والعسكري تتضمن تنفيذ
الترتيبات الامنيه المنصوص عليها في اتفاق
جوبا للسلام ودمج الدعم السريع في القوات
المسلحه
اكدت شرطه سودانيه ان قوات الاحتياط
المركزي فصيل تابع لها وقد تم الدفع به
الى الشوارع لتامين الاسواق وممتلكات
المواطنين وشددت على ان من يقودها هم
خريجو كليه الشرطه والقانون وقالت الشرطه
ردا على الدعم السريع في البيان انه لا
وجود للامن الشعبي في قوات الاحتياط
المركزي مؤكده بان مقر البنك المركز
الرئيسي لم يتعرض لاي هجوم وان الحريق
الذي تم الاعلان عنه يعود لاحد فروع البنك
السودان اسبوع ثالث من القتال
مخاوف من ان يؤدي الصراع الى حرب طويله
الامد
صراع انفجر منتصف ابريل ولم يهدا بعد
طرفات صراع الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
قرر المواجهه بالسلاح وتبادل الاتهامات
اعلاميا
حصيله كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
الاف الفرينه الى دول الجوار وعمليات
اجلاء كبيره ومستمره
واستظروف انسانيه صعبه
هدنه معلنه وجهود دوليه لوقف القتال
لكن اعمده الدخان لم تغب عن سماء الخرطوم
وفي تطور انساني كانت اعلنت لجنه الدوليه
لصليب الاحمر عن ارسالها لاول شحنه
مساعدات ثانيه من العاصمه الاردني عمان
الى بورتسودان وقالت اللجنه في بيان ان
شحنه المرسله مؤلفه من ثمانيه اطنان من
المعدات الجراحيه لدعم مستشفيات السودان
ومتطوعي جمعيه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
بالاضافه الى مواد تخدير وادوات تضميد
ولوازم خياطه الجروح وغيرها من المعدات
الجراحيه التي يمكن ان تستخدم لعلاج الاف
الاشخاص الذين اصيبوا بجروح جراء
الاشتباكات في السودان
هذا وتحاول منظمات تطوعيه في السودان
تعويض التوقف التام للمستشفيات المتخصصه
في الولاده حيث تقدم الخدمات الصحيه لعدد
من الحوامل في ظل شبه الانهيار للنظام
الصحي السوداني وقدر صندوق الامم المتحده
للسكان عدد النساء الحوامل في الخرطوم ب
220 الف امراه معرضه للخطر
السيد حامل في الخرطوم 24 الف من هنا على
شكل وضعف الاسابيع المقبله حسب تقديرات
المتحده لسكان 60 مستشفى هو الان خارج عن
الخدمه من ضمنهم مستشفى من ضمن للولاده
اكبر مستشفيات الولاده في السودان الامر
الذي دعم منظمه
لتمويل تشغيل مستشفى الندى عن طريق منظمه
سابا المستشفى حاليا بيقدم خدمات الولاده
الطبيعيه والقيصريه بصوره مجانيه بالكامل
بالاضافه الى خدمات
الرعايه الصحيه للاطفال
زادت المخاوف من كارثه كبيره في توفير
الدواء في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطومه مع
دخول الاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع اسبوعها السادس نتابع
صيدليات مغلقه ورفوف ادويه شبه فارغ هذه
حصيله نحو اسبوعين من الاشتباكات يضاف لها
عمليه نهب واسعه طالت صيدليات ومخازن
ادويه في العاصمه السودانيه هنا في مدينه
ام درمان يستمر اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في ظل
تحذيرات من تفاقم الازمه الصحيه على مستوى
البلاد حاليا الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك في ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه اللي بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي
او الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
دي الناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في الحي
الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفره في الظروف
العاديه فيها شحو الان المشكله بقت اكبر
تهدد الازمه الحاليه صحه الكبار والصغار
على حد سواء فاسعار الادويه بارتفاع مستمر
فيما اصنافها المتوفره بانخفاض مقلق ومن
وجد الاحداث الدوحه من سنين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن او ذاتي فتشوا ما خلوا
اي حته فتش عشان القليل ما لقوليه ويسعد
ما خلينا صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا حتى ما
لقينا وحتى عربيه
ما في بنزين ما في هناك طريقه نمرق من
البلد عشان نمشي نفتش الدواء نجيبه اما
بالنسبه للمستشفيات فلا يزال القليل منها
الذي يعمل في الخرطوم يعاني نقصا حادا في
الادويه والمستلزمات العلاجيه الاخرى خاصه
المتعلقه
بالجرحى والمحاليل الوريديه ما يفاقم من
معاناه المرضى مع استمرار توقف الامداد
الدوائي الحكومي نور الحصني العربيه
متابعه هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم
الدكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه سكرتير ونقابه
اطباء السودان دكتور عطيه اهلا بك معنا هل
يمكن القول فعلا بان انهيار النظام الصحي
في السودان بات وشيكا كما ذكرتم سابقا
والاهم ما الذي سيترتب عن ذلك
في السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وعليكم السلام
امنيات الصحه والعافيه لكل الجرحى والمرضى
وعوده حميدا لكل المفقودين نعم انهيار
النظام الصحي اصبح رائعين نراه قريبا
لعدد من العوامل التي منذ اليوم الاول من
هذه الحرب ظللنا نتخوف منه وهو النقصان
الحادثين في الامدادات الطبيه
وانعدام لهذه الممرات الامنه
وضماناتها وايضا كذلك الان
حتى هي حركه الكوادر الطبيه
اكثر واقعيه هذا الموضوع لما نتحدث عن
انهيار نظام صحي نتحدث عن ماذا بالتحديد
نتحدث عن انه ليس هناك مخزون ادويه كافي
نتحدث عن تعطل المستشفيات فصل لنا اكثر
هذه التفاصيل اين تكمن المخاوف
كل ما ذكرتيه هي عوامل عديده تحدد انهيار
النظام الصحي او فشله من بينها هي العدد
المستشفيات العامله وطاقتها الاستيعابيه
وايضا امكانياتها امكانياتها لتلقي عدد من
المرضى ايضا وجود كافي للمعينات الطبيه
والمستهلكات الطبيه امكانيه
وحريه حركه الكوادر الطبيه من والى
المستشفيات ايضا كذلك هي
الامراض هنالك الامراض الغير ايضا الضغط
والسكري كما ذكر تقريركم قبل قليل هنالك
مراقبه
[موسيقى]
لاحصيل ايضا من من
الامراض الاوبئه التي قد تحدث في كل لحظه
الان السودان المواجه
[موسيقى]
بانتشار لامراض عديده بعد التخلص ما هذه
الاوبئه التي ذكرتها وتتخوفون منها
اولها هي الامراض او الكوارث البيولوجيه
التي نتحدث عنها بعد احتلال الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
معمل سباق القومي هنالك عدد من العينات
التي تؤثر وتشكل خطر بيولوجي على الشعب
السوداني
ايضا ونحن نحن نتحدث عن عن هنالك يعني
الان تراكم المياه في الشوارع وايضا
النفايات الموجوده كلها هي اخطار بيئيه
ايضا هنالك توقف عدد من محطات المياه لا
يمكن يعني توصيل مياه نقيه للشرب
صحيح وانقطاع المياه موضوع كان مرافق لكل
هذه الازمه منذ اليوم الاول ولكن ما
الحلول دكتور يعني في اخر التطورات كانت
اعلنت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
ارسالها اول شحنه مساعدات انتم ومن خلالكم
نقابه الاطباء في داخل السوداني هل لديكم
علم بهذه الشحنه
بتفاصيل وصولها بموعد الوصول اقصد وكيف
سيتم توزيعها خاصه
اولا نشكر اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
وكل الشركاء في المنظمات الدوليه التي
حركت يعني عدد من الشحنات العالميه في
طريقها الى السودان نحن نتابع معهم
ونشكرهم جزيلا انا الشعب السوداني نحن
نتمنى ان تصل هذه الشحنه الى مستحقيها وان
لا يتعرض اليها طرفي الصراع في السودان
ايضا يعني نطالب بسلامه موظفي هذه
المنظمات الدوليه التي تعمل الليله نهار
لايصال المساعدات للشعب السوداني امكانيات
وصولها الى المستشفيات هو ايضا الان هو
محفوف بالمخاطر في ظل انعدام الممرات
الامنه نحن نشكرهم جدا وندائنا يتصل لبقيه
المنظمات الدوليه المجتمع الدولي بارسال
جسور جويه وبريه واباحيه لمشاهده الشعب
السوداني
عندما تصلكم مثل هكذا المساعدات لما نتحدث
عن مساعده من اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر هل يمكن ان تراقب وخاصه ان تقوم
بتوزيع هذه المساعدات جهه امميه او ان
العادي بانكم انتم يعني في داخل السوداني
تتسلمون هذه المساعدات
وتوكل لكم مهمه التوزيع
بالتاكيد هم يقومون نحن يعني كلنا نعمل مع
بعض ثم يقومون بتوصيل هذه
المساعدات نحن
نمدهم بالمستشفيات
والمشافي التي في في الحوجه الماده نحن
نعمل مع بعض لانه
اكيد هنالك مانحين يريدون تقرير او فيدباك
على هذه المعونات لا يمكن ان تذهب هذه
المعونات الى اي طرف ثالث ونحن نؤكد على
ذلك ونرجو من طرفي الصراع عدم التعرض الى
هذه الطبيه نعم
الخرطوم الدكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه
سكرتيرو نقابه اطباء السودان شكرا لك
دكتور
حاليا نحن في المنطقه بتاعه المرسى
المواطنين والسكان في المنطقه مثل مناطق
المجاوره من هنا مباشره من النيل شيلو
مويه بتاع الشرب شيلوها من النيل ومن هنا
من المرسى وانت ماشي فالناس بتعاني جدعاني
شديد جدعان
تتحرك به من المناطق الصدريه
وهنا والمنطقه خطيره شديد يعني
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نشير الى هذا
العاجل نراه اسفل الشاشه سلطات الطيران
المدنيه السوداني تمدد اغلاق المجال الجوي
باستثناء طائرات الاجلاء والمساعدات اذا
سلطات الطيران المدني السوداني تمدد اغلاق
المجال الجوي باستثناء طائرات الاجلاء
والمساعدات الى اخبار اخرى ذات خلافه مع
استمرار عمليات السلب والنهب في بعض مناطق
الصرع في السودان اظهرت صور قيام افراد
بسرقه احد مصانع شركات التبغ في منطقه
الخرطوم بحري فيما اعلنت قوه الشرطه نشر
قواتها للسيطره على الوضع الامني
هذا واظهر مقطع فيديو محاولات سرقه بنك
الخرطوم في مدينه اندرمان متابع
[موسيقى]
والله
وفي تطورات اخرى لتداعيات هذه الاشتباكات
قال رئيس حزب الامم السوداني للعربيه انها
قوه دعم السريع اقتحمت منزله وسرقه المنزل
واتلفت عددا من الوثائق
كانوا يبحثوا
كثير من الوثائق ليس فقط انهم كسروا الخزن
واخذوا ذهب السيدات وغيره لكن كانوا
يبحثوا عن في كان ينظر في الوثائق
الخاصه بي
افراغ كثير من هذه الوثائق
ورموها على الارض بشكل يعني واضح
مبارك الفاضل المهدي قال ان الحاله
السياسي في السودان صعب كونه هناك تمرد
عسكري على الجيش كما وصف
شوف الان
سياسي لانه هذا تمرد عسكري والقوات
المسلحه قرارها هي ان تنهي هذا التمرد
عسكريا او يستسلم الذين ما زالوا في
الخرطوم لانه معسكرات الدعم السريع في كل
السودان استسلمت في 16 ولايه الان واستلمت
يعني اسلحتها
قرار القوات المسلحه الان
قبلوا وساطه الايات ولكن في اطار انه هذه
الوساطه ستنظر في استعام ما تبقى من الدعم
السريع في القوات المسلحه
حضرا الخاصه السابق الى القرن الافريقي
جيفري فيلتمان من لقاء او في لقاء مع
صحيفه الجاردين من اطاله امد الصراع في
السودان لانه سيفتح الباب امام جهات
خارجيه تدعم جنرال على حساب اخر بحسب قوله
الصراع في السودان الى منحا اخر وربما
ينتهي بتدخل خارجي لنصره احد جنرال النزاع
ما ينذر بحرب اهليه طويله الامد تقول
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه
الصحيفه نقلت عن الدبلوماسي الامريكي
ومبعوثها الخاص السابق الى القرن الافريقي
جيفري قوله انه كلما طال امد الصراع سيسمح
لجهات خارجيه خبيثه بدعم جنرال على حساب
اخر
رجل امريكا السابق للقرن الافريقي اكد على
ان الساحه متاحه امام القوات الخارجيه في
اشاره الى مجموعه
ولذلك يتوجب وقف الاقتتال في اسرع وقت
ممكن لتقويد التحرك الخارجي
تحذيراتمان لم تاتي من فراغ على ما يبدو
بعد ان كشف القائد السابق لفاينر مرات
موجوده في السودان منذ نهايه العام
2017 مؤكدا ان هناك 200 عنصر من الوحده
الهجوميه الاولى داخل الاراضي السودانيه
حيث كانت مكلفه بتدريب قوات الدعم السريع
والشرطه المحليه
التحذيرات جاءت ايضا من الداخل على لسان
قائد جيش عبد الفتاح البرهان الذي كشف عن
وجود مرتزقه داخل السودان قدمت من دول
تشاد
هي الوسطى والنيجر
رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله
حمدوك حذر هو الاخر من امكانيه اندلاع حرب
اهليه في السودان ستشكل كابوسا قاطما على
البلاد والعالم محاسن حداره العربيه
رصدت كاميرا العربيه وصولا سفينتين
عسكريتين تتبعني للجيش الامريكي
والبريطاني ورصدت وصولهما الى مينا
بورسودان لاجلاء رعاياها ورعايا دول اخرى
وصل الان قبل قليل هذه القطعه
العسكريه البحريه الضخمه التي تتبع للجيش
الامريكي وصلت قبل قليل الى ميناء
بورسودان هذه القطعه التي تتبع للبحريه
الامريكيه ستعمل على نقل نحو 300 من رعايه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا سفينه
تتبع الجيش البريطاني هذه السفينه ايضا
رست قبل قليل في ميناء بورسودان هذه
السفينه مزوده بطائره حربيه
الى جانب ايضا وجود للجيش البريطاني الذي
جاء بمعيه هذه القطعه البحريه ستعمل ايضا
كما علمنا على نقل رعايه بريطانيين وعدد
من دول اوروبا وعدد من الدول العربيه
وممثلين لبعثات الدبلوماسيه
ايضا رصد مراسل العربيه نزار البداوي
احوال العالقين الذين ينتظرون الخروج من
البلاد نحو اليوم العاشر تمضي عمليات
الاجلاء لرعايه الدول العربيه والاجنبيه
والاسيويه من شرق السودان الى عدد من
الدول في المنطقه اكثر من نحو عشره الاف
من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه تم اجلائهم خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه عبر ميناء
بورسودان وما يقدر لاكثر من سته الاف
غادروا عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي الى
وجهات دوليه مختلفه ومع استمرار عمليات
الاجلاء الا ان مئات من الاسر السوريه
واليمنيه ما تزال حتى اليوم في انتظار
استكمال اجراءات مغادرتها للبلاد احنا
مطالبين اكثر
من اي بلد يقعدوا في الناس او يستضيفوهم
شكرا احنا بس بدنا ممر امن من هنا الى
الحدود السوريه وشكرا
البعض فضل البقاء داخل مركز التسجيل
والحصر هنا واخرون عملت السلطات المحليه
على توفير دور مؤقته لاوائهم في ظل ظروف
يحاول الجهد الرسمي والشعبي بمدينه
تخفيف وطاتها على العائلات والنساء
والاطفال الموجودين حاليا بشرق السودان
نزار البداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث مدينه
بورسودان شرقيه السودان
فوضيه الساميه لحقوق الانسان ان تتضاعف
اعداد او يتضاعف اعداد اللاجئين
السودانيين مضحتا ان 75 الفا نزحوا في
الداخل السوداني فيما فر اخرون الى دول
الخارج بسبب الاسماء
احد اكبر تجمعات اللاجئين في افريقيا
بتلاجئا السودان ومع كل قصف يعكر سماءه
تتضاعف اعداد نازحيه وتوقعات امميه بفرار
مئات الالاف مفوضيه الامم المتحده قالت ما
لا يقل عن 75 الف شخص نزحوا داخليا بسبب
الازمه فيما بلغ عدد المشردين قرابه ثلاثه
ملايين الف شخص معظمهم في منطقه غرب
دارفور المضطربه بينما 37 الف شخص نزحوا
عبر مدينه نيالا وثلاثون الفا توجهوا
جنوبا الى النيل الابيض فالسودان لم يعد
ملاذا امنا هرب اخرون الى الخارج
التقديرات تشير الى ان 20 الفا عبروا الى
تشاد وقد ترتفع الاعداد الى 100 الف بحسب
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره و14 اخرين اتجهوا
الى مصر وذا ت العدد لكن الى جنوب السودان
اما اثيوبيا فاستقبلت
3500 شخص ولاد بالفرار الى افريقيا الوسطى
1300 بينهم 500 طفل وامراه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات